is it weird
if i asked like a friend who's just a
girl because i've seen all my
guy friends as penis as a comic you know
what i mean where
would it be everywhere
yeah yeah oh the pittsburgh can probably
be everywhere you know what i mean
everywhere on a roller coaster you know
i mean it doesn't yeah it's improv yes
yeah yeah yeah so um
but it's like i have female friends
that i don't have any sexual desires or
i think this is a friend i would just
love to see their genitals that's all
sure sure sure but it's because of the
climate and stuff you can't have i've
never asked and it's weird right because
of the client because it's the climate
it's hot and stuffy down there it's too
hot for me to show you my pussy the
climate right now is just it's too hot
outside
um i feel like i've shown you you've
seen my boobs i feel like you have yeah
yeah pretty good not the new ones you
have new ones
no
i don't think i've seen i don't think
i've dicks are easier to whip out and
put back on the vaginas like by the time
you show it to someone as a joke you've
like caught a disease right it's an open
wound like you can't they're dick like
that's my whole thing whenever i was
like he just like pulled his dick out
like it's a very easy thing to do to
pull your dick out yeah but i'm not
asking to see the lips
i'm just asking to see just the
entry part
you know how you see like a beautiful
house
you'd love to see what's inside but it's
like something you just drive by you
want to do like a drive-by and just see
the shutters that's right you just want
to okay but i want to see what style it
is
to how close you can be to a platonic
friend of the opposite sex if you
haven't seen their genitals yeah it is
it is wild because it's like if i don't
know what you're working with it is hard
to advise you on many things so like for
example i remember a girlfriend of mine
who uh um
like you know i'm just gonna say her
name fuck it stephanie simbari uh we
were like we were a girlfriend she
opened for me on the road for a while
it's a good friend and we're like
touring together and she's like having
all these like guy problems and this and
this and then one time we were in soul
cycle and i saw her completely naked and
i was like
wait had i known this was your body i
would have given you different advice
this whole time
what do you mean do not text him back
you are totally i just hadn't seen her
like fully naked and it's like she just
has the most incredible body like most
incredible like tits like incred like
she had this like like pubes everywhere
i was like bitch you like
when i saw her naked i was like you
don't need to play any games with any
guy they should be i just hadn't seen
what she was working with right and i
know that sounds insane it was like
emily the first time i saw emily i've
known her for eight years and then i all
of a sudden we discovered that she's got
giant like
big pendulous naturals
we all discovered we discovered at the
same time
i'm like i would have dealt with you
completely differently these past eight
years knowing that you had these like
honkers i was like you're a bully now
like i used to feel like like you were
allowed to have low self-esteem but now
that i've seen your tits like how dare
you you know like it's so it's like it's
stuff like that i if i
it's like when you find out when your
guy friends has like a giant dick
you're like
i i like it just changes
it changes the way you advise them you
view them
i was okay with paulie shore until i saw
his penis does he have a giant dick it's
not just giant it it does this is it the
size of a weasel
it it you know it's like a you know how
you go to magic mountain there's that
one ride you're like ah nope you know
it's like that nope yep and it's so
veiny
by the way can you put i want to do a
master class with comedians where they
think they're making sense but it's just
more confusing
[Music]
[Applause]